hey everyone
I mean Boswell team sky today with sis
to do a behind-the-scenes view of what I
get up to a nice and in the final
preparation of my soul Pond California
so come on in
so I'm just back from a bike ride today
and got inside taking a shower and
getting ready to to wash my bike here
for a team ride tomorrow we have some
intervals to do and yet so this is my
house I've been living here for five
years in Nice France this is my
girlfriend Gretchen who keeps me staying
here when I'm not riding my bike this is
my fifth year and nice I moved out in
December 2012 on I guess suggestion from
from Team Sky there actually is a really
good support structure down here in me
so we have a little team house slash
service course over in Beaujolais the
kind of promote riders to be here so we
think training as a group we can travel
as a group we can you know we have
access to massage we have access to
physiotherapy you can load up on
nutritional products from sis ships tons
of stuff down to load us up so riders
can go by pick up all sorts of products
so started to plan my tour California
bit I've started to incorporate some of
the the courses that I can simulate here
and nice with my training my nutrition
lead at the Tour California has been
really important my weight is on track
which I'm happy to say you know the
weights one side of it but also managing
and how you're going to fuel in the
races and you know one thing that I
believe in is training like you race so
if you're always training with a certain
type of food or not race food then you
go to a race you start eating a bunch of
gels but you're not necessarily used to
it you might have a strange reaction so
for me just knowing what works for me
and went in my training and then will
transfer that into races is really
important my biggest challenge for tour
California is probably going to be the
Big Bear time control there's a junior I
was good at um trolls but over the last
couple years I've kind of let my time
Charlene drift by the wayside so
you know really practice makes perfect
in that situation money it's just
something that I don't necessarily enjoy
riding my time trial bike but I'm
learning to embrace well just getting
back in from the ride we did for hours
we went out the team with frou me Garen
Thomas
Kenny Ella song Diego Rosa we had four
hours yeah I had a few efforts today we
did a few longer climbs back in the
hills of called the Browse which is
about a 20 minute climb 25 minutes so I
was doing some efforts to kind of
simulate Mount Baldy which is the queen
stage of the Tour California so as we
get closer to the event I'm starting to
prepare more specifically for for that
specific day really and trying to find
climbs here where I live in East to
simulate that type of effort I was
fortunate today to have a follow car
behind me so I had plenty of gels with
me mixed in the bottle and now we're
back and I'm going to have a recovery
drink now and then I think the chef is
prepared to munch floor so let's go get
some food yes we're here now a couple
weeks out from California which has been
my target race and since January really
at the team and I set out as a goal to
myself to lead the team you know it's a
big race for myself being an American
and being the first first year as a
World Tour race so I'm still not sure
what the peloton is going to be but
it'll definitely be some good riders
thanks for coming in visiting our French
home and we'll see you all in California
thanks
you
you